the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC a major night of news involving the
alleged sale of presidential pardons
sexual harassment anti-semitic remarks
all sorts of allegations against Rudy
Giuliani Donald Trump is implicated in
these allegations and we'll get to that
sort of subsequently but let's start
with where this all began which is a
lawsuit the lawsuit has been filed by
Noel Dunphy we are naming her despite
her status as the alleged Victim Because
she has gone public this is not a
situation where uh there is a Jane Doe
who's uh looking to remain anonymous at
least publicly daily Beast article
explains harassment suit against Rudy
Giuliani full of graphic allegations a
New York woman says the ex-mayor
sexually harassed her while she was
working for him claims that he
previously denied when you look at the
article you learn about the 70-page
complaint filed in New York Supreme
Court
this goes back to January where Noelle
dunfee filed the summons says she was
hired by Rudy in 2019 for so-called
Business Development work that he did
not pay her as promised and subsequently
fired her in 2021. the summons also
alleges that Rudy Giuliani made
anti-semitic and racist remarks during
quote confused and hostile alcohol-laced
tirades and demanded sexual favors the
lawsuit was filed Monday remember the
first step was the summons in January we
now have a lawsuit the lawsuit includes
extraordinary detail much of it probably
inappropriate for this show it includes
allegations of forced oral sex and
intercourse details of Rudy's sexual
preferences which is gag worthy the
Revelation that Dunphy recorded some of
the interactions there are tapes lordy
there are tapes and the lawsuit seeks 10
million dollars in Damages a statement
was put out by Rudy at Giuliani
vehemently and completely denies the
allegations
plans to thoroughly defend himself that
it is harassment and attempted extortion
uh I don't know that we need to go
through all of these elements but they
relate to demands from Rudy that Dunphy
work naked or in American flag Laden
short shorts that he purchased for her
these are like hyper-specific
allegations I mentioned the forced oral
sex
Rudy talking about fantasies related to
the television show billions that Rudy
was constantly taking Viagra and would
sometimes dear God Point his erect penis
and say work couldn't be done until that
was dealt with
um video conferences would include
requests or demands for disrobing there
were text messages where these are
included the I mean this you know it's
much tougher when there are recordings
and text messages to write this all off
as made up
um requests to shower together
um
it it's all it's all outrageous and then
one of the big elements of this which
we're going to discuss on its own
because it is so outrageous dunfee this
is now from the article dunfee claims
Giuliani told her he was able to quote
break the law
because he has quote immunity
and asked if she knew anyone who needs a
pardon because he was selling them for
two million dollars
he told Miss Dunphy that he she could
refer individuals seeking pardons to him
so long as they did not go through the
normal channels of the office of the
pardon attorney because then they'd be
subject to disclosure and this goes on
and on and on a 2020's plan in February
2019 the complaint notes Giuliani told
Dunphy about Trump's plan if he were to
lose specifically Giuliani said to
Dunphy Trump would claim there was voter
fraud and say he won
this was discussed at several meetings
with Giuliani and Lev parnis this is
absolutely stunning stuff absolutely
stunning stuff there's another article
which we won't go through in details
from Business Insider Rudy hit with
bombshell rape lawsuit ex-staffer says
he demanded oral sex while he took calls
from Donald Trump
um has America ever been more wrong
about someone than about Rudy Giuliani
after 9 11. I mean that's one question
that certainly comes up Bill Cosby I
guess maybe and so much of the last five
years now has to be sort of Revisited or
reinterpreted through the lens of this
lawsuit if you believe it to be credible
and I have no reason at this point uh to
to doubt it there are audio recordings
there are text messages there is this is
genuinely a bombshell when we think back
to that Borat scene Sasha Baron Cohen
where Rudy Giuliani after the fact said
oh I was just tucking in my shirt
it certainly seems less harmless in the
wake of these new allegations Dunphy has
receipts twenty thousand emails text
messages and recordings and let's not
ignore this is a lawsuit this is a civil
proceeding let's not ignore the
potential for some of those documents
and records to become relevant in
potential criminal investigations
against Rudy Giuliani so that's the
lawsuit let's now focus in on the pardon
aspect of this Donald Trump and Rudy
Giuliani are accused of plotting to sell
presidential pardons as Trump's time in
the Oval Office was winding down for the
very affordable price quite frankly in
context of two million dollars a piece a
former staffer says in a lawsuit we've
already discussed the uh outrageous
sexual assault allegations that are part
of this lawsuit from former Giuliani
Stafford Noelle Dunphy earlier in the
show I now want to focus in on the
presidential pardon part there's a
Business Insider article that summarizes
this quite well on Monday Rudy Giuliani
was hit with a bombshell rape civil
lawsuit filed by a former staffer the
staffer alleged in the lawsuit that
Giuliani asked if she knew anyone who
wanted to buy a presidential pardon the
suit says Giuliani said he was telling
them selling them for two million
dollars splitting the profit with Donald
Trump
now
where do you even start with this we
have said many times over the last
months an allegation is made against
Donald Trump and it's written off as
obviously not believable and then
another allegation is made that is very
similar and another one and there are
records and lordy there are tapes or
whatever the case may be there are
already pre-existing allegations that
there were all sorts of different ways
that potential pardons were being
shopped and uh representatives were
bringing them to Trump and there were
rumors of what about some kind of
financial aspect to this and now there's
a lawsuit which says under penalty of
perjury that there was a plan between
Giuliani and Trump to sell pardons for
two million dollars a piece and to split
the money is this proof that that was
taking place no
is this proof that they did it and sold
any pardons it is not proof but it is
again corroboration of a pattern that
has been alleged from sources who have
no interaction with each other and don't
know each other now one of the most
important questions to ask here and it's
a fair question and it's a question that
we should ask is it explicitly illegal
for the president of the United States
to sell pardons the reason we have to
ask this question is one of the things
we learned during the Trump presidency
is that just because
there are things that Trump did or is
accused of doing that no former
president tried to do that is not a
guarantee that the thing Trump tried to
do is actually against the law and to
some degree one of the things that
Donald Trump exposed through his
presidency is that the checks and
balances and separations of powers that
the founders of the Constitution put in
place never expected or assumed that
there would be someone in power like
Trump who might try to circumvent them
but let's get to the question is it
explicitly illegal for a president to
sell pardons
my research is that it is not explicitly
illegal there is not an explicit
provision that says a president can't
sell pardons or can't receive benefits
in exchange for pardons benefits could
be all sorts of different things however
and this is where so many of these
issues get complicated there are legal
experts that have said even without an
explicit provision saying you can't sell
a pardon as president
you could indeed as a president selling
pardons be violating other federal laws
bribery you just because you're the
president and you're not explicitly
barred from selling pardons doesn't mean
you couldn't be charged with bribery uh
in accepting money for a pardon fraud
obstruction of justice obstruction of
justice is an interesting one imagine
that the president sells a pardon to
someone who's under investigation or
under prosecution by the justice
department
by pardoning them potentially
preemptively you are effectively
interfering with the administration of
justice because you're saying whatever
the facts point to whatever the justice
department justice department thinks
they have based on the facts and the
evidence
I'm issuing a preemptive pardon you're
interfering with the administration of
justice and thus it could be an abusive
power or obstruction of justice that all
being said those are not explicit
Provisions that make it illegal for the
president of the United States to sell a
pardon and this is we learn this time
and time again with Trump
we don't actually have strong enough
checks and balances many of us might
have assumed for a long time no one like
Trump will ever come to power so we
don't need to worry about some of these
checks and balances that aren't strong
enough well we very quickly learned that
we do need to worry about it we will see
where this goes stunning Blockbuster
stuff
Twitter owner Elon Musk says he is for
free speech one of the realities about
being for free speech
is that you have to before Free Speech
or for speech that sometimes might cause
uncomfortable consequences this is the
reality for so-called Free Speech
absolutists we are now learning that
Elon Musk limited Tweets in Turkey
during the tight presidential election
in which president erdogan on Sunday
failed to get to the 50 threshold and
now as a result that election will go to
a runoff
uh there is a rolling stone article
Vanity Fair sorry Twitter's Elon Musk
defends decision to limit Tweets in
Turkey during tight presidential
election uh oh is this free speech
critics say the social media platform
allowed the Turkish government to
silence criticism this is an article
from a couple days ago by Jack mccordick
on the eve of the most hotly contested
Turkish election in two decades Twitter
uh-oh moved to block posts in the
country in what critics argue is a
capitulation to a call for censorship
from Turkish president erdogan
in response to legal process and to
ensure Twitter remains available to the
people of Turkey
we have taken action to restrict access
to some content in Turkey today uh oh a
second tweet said the restricted content
would be visible to the rest of the
world
as we know and as the Vanity Fair
article explains during his 20 years as
president erdogan has methodically
tightened his grip on power undermining
key Democratic institutions
Adam Schiff former guest on this program
tweeted the day before a critical
election in Turkey Twitter appears to be
acquiescing to the demands of the
country's autocratic ruler erdogan and
is censoring speech on the platform
given Twitter's total lack of
transparency it is hard to avoid the
conclusion that musk's Promises of free
speech have again Fallen away
uh Twitter didn't say which accounts it
restricted but Turkish minute reported
the censored accounts include Kurdish
businessman Muhammad yakut who claimed
erdogan staged a 2016 coup attempt an
investigative journalist Savari guvin
who reports on corruption in the country
quote it's a disgrace to democracy and
freedom of expression that Twitter has
caved to erdogan Saturday Elon Musk
Twitter CEO and self-proclaimed Free
Speech absolutist defended the
Restriction musk said did your brain
fall out of your head responding to
Matthew Iglesias the choice is have
Twitter throttled in its entirety
or limit access to some tweets which one
do you want now of course the true Free
Speech absolutist would say we are not
going to bow to your authoritarian
threats to block all of Twitter we will
not censor particular tweets at your
demand and if you do block Twitter in
some total we will shout from the
rooftops and make it a global story of
authoritarian censorship that's how a
free speech absolutist would handle
those threats but Elon Musk said all
right we'll limit the content that
erdogan wants limited sadly
this is too common among those who claim
that they are for free speech and we've
talked about it before with the Maga
people free speech Free Speech Free
Speech oh forced Twitter to publish my
coveted disinformation otherwise they're
bad and we will try to uh restrict them
or in some some persecute them uh in the
court of public opinion or potentially
even legally well then you're not really
for the free speech of that Corporation
are you now is it Twitter's right
to restrict access to whatever they want
sure
no one's denying that what we're talking
about is the selective application of
so-called Free Speech absolutism from
self-proclaimed Free Speech Heroes like
Elon Musk we'll continue to cover it
Monday Memorial Day we are doing a
one-day membership special that is going
to knock your socks off it's going to be
crazy people probably should just wear
flip-flops at the time to not even have
to deal with the socks being knocked off
get on my mailing list at
davidpackman.com Monday Memorial day
you'll get an email telling you how to
take advantage of this stunning and
appalling membership discount
if you are still looking for the perfect
Father's Day gift check this out guys
know that it can be tough to find good
boxers and t-shirts but the search can
end now because our sponsor Leisure of
NYC sells the most comfortable t-shirts
and boxers that your dad is ever going
to wear all boxer briefs by Leisure of
NYC are made with amazingly soft
moisture wicking viscose from bamboo
feels lightweight like air but it
doesn't Bunch up it's also better for
the planet Leisure of NYC also makes
these incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's really the best out
there it just feels almost like Silk you
can let your dad walk around in a
scratchy t-shirt all day but come on you
can also treat him with the cloud soft
feel of supine cotton so that it'll
actually love the shirt these are always
my go-to shirts and boxers no other
company even comes close to the Comfort
they provide and all of their products
are fair trade and made sustainably go
to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below
in the latest example of Ron DeSantis
showing he's simply not ready for prime
time and certainly not in a position to
actually win a Republican primary which
he may very well enter there are now
rumors that he will announce in the next
week or so Ron DeSantis was asked
yesterday did Trump lose in 2020 can you
just say like Trump lost there wasn't
all this fraud that Donald Trump talked
about and DeSantis weasels out and
refuses to actually answer the question
instead talking about how there's a
culture of losing in the Republican
party and blah blah blah blah this is
not a strategy that is going to win him
the primary I will explain why after we
look at the clip listen to this standing
for absolutely nothing that should be
Ron desantis's campaign motto
a culture of losing do you acknowledge
that Trump lost and there wasn't all
this raw that he talked about
well I look at the last however many
election Cycles 2018 we lost the house
we lost the Senate 2020 Biden becomes
president or no excuse me we lost the
senate in 2020 Biden becomes president
and has done a huge amount of damage
very unpopular in 2022 and we are
supposed to have this big red wave and
other than like Florida and Iowa I
didn't see a red wave across this
country and so I think the party has
developed a culture of losing I think
that there's not accountability and I
think in Florida we really showed what
it takes to not just win the question
was did Trump lose these people are
these are not serious people win big and
then deliver big and ultimately when
you're doing all this uh what results
are you producing for people that's
really what matters uh you can sit there
and talk about cable news social media
all these other things that's not what
the reporter was talking about the
reporter just said Trump lose things
that that people are fixated on and for
me it's like okay what's that true north
uh you obviously got to win otherwise
you don't get a ticket to the dance and
did Trump win you're not answering the
question sir once you do that how are
you going to be able to actually bring
about big change to make people's lives
better next
yeah next yeah this is not going to cut
it my friends this this is wishy-washy
weak nonsense
DeSantis is probably afraid of
alienating the loyal Trump base and the
loyal Trump base still seems to believe
the obvious lie the obvious lie that
Trump lost I'm sorry the obvious lie
that Trump won in 2020 they are unable
to accept the reality that their guy
simply didn't win and so DeSantis is
calculating well I can't just say yeah
Trump lost and he should accept it
because I might need some of those
supporters but the problem is that when
you're asked did Trump lose and you rant
for 80 Seconds about the midterms and
who the hell knows what else you
alienate
every American who's sick and tired of
the Trump lie that he actually won in
2020 which is of course
almost every Democrat the vast majority
of Independents and many Republicans as
well although certainly not all so
DeSantis wants to have it both ways here
he wants to be seen as a great
alternative to Trump to the Loyalists
and in order to do that you have to sort
of appeal to Trump's hardcore fans but
he also wants to be seen as the
pragmatic leader who can win over
moderates and independents and is
willing to just talk in a sensible way
but he seems completely unable to do
both you can't be an alternative to
Trump
if you can't just acknowledge what
happened in 2020 you can't be the leader
of the future if you can't say
definitively and clearly the 2020 thing
is over Trump lost Biden won period so
DeSantis I think is going to need to
make a choice if he wants to actually
have a shot at this thing which may he
may already not have you either stand up
to Trump and say listen
we share some values we disagree on
others but we need to ensure that
there's a future for the Republican
party we don't have that future if we
keep Dilly dallying about just saying
what needs to be said we were beaten by
Biden in 2020 right that that's one no
ambiguity no evasion we need Clarity
honesty I will never lie to you and the
truth is Trump lost that's one approach
it probably infuriates a bunch of the
Loyalists and therefore there is no
chance that they will even consider
coming over to to DeSantis the other
aspect to this is maybe what DeSantis is
trying to do
is just avoid the issue of 2020. like it
could be calculated it's it's it's not
about well I don't want to offend the
Trump loyalists or whatever but he's
just saying I'm going to play dumb and
ignore the issue all together the
problem with that is you're not going to
appeal to enough Republicans who want a
fresh start and a new Direction you're
not going to win back the people that
Republicans lost with all of this Libs
if you don't very clearly Inspire
confidence by saying I'm willing to
Simply tell the truth and so it's really
a problem for DeSantis and of course the
bigger problem for desensis is a
mathematical one which is no matter
which of these approaches he takes
the average polling right now is roughly
Trump 53 DeSantis 23 plus or minus a
couple points and as I've said before
simple math if Trump already has more
than 50 of the Republican primary vote
DeSantis can't win even with every
non-trump vote it would only get him to
47 percent DeSantis somehow needs to get
some Trump voters to switch to him and I
don't think this approach is going to
help him he may be popular in Florida
he's not ready for prime time he's not
ready to take on Biden but never mind
that he's not even ready to take on
Trump so we'll see if we get an
announcement from him uh latest rumors
are anywhere in the next seven to 14
days one to two weeks we may be hearing
that announcement from uh Rob Des
sanctimonious as he was most recently
called by Trump on Truth Central there
was a whacked out event at Trump's Doral
Resort in Florida where Dr Peter
McCullough one of the big we I guess I
would call him like an anti-vac
pseudoscience dignitary Who Rose in the
age of covid Dr Peter McCullough see if
you can follow this okay he suggested at
this completely Bonkers event
the covet vaccines
cause autism
autism turns people trans
therefore using our what is that the
commutative property from algebra
pre-algebra therefore vaccinations cause
trans this is really weaponized stuff it
must be something happening to the
children something in the in the air in
the water or the food one theory is that
it's hypervaccination from an
accelerating childhood vaccine schedule
huh so he's saying it's it's vaccines in
general not even just the covet vaccine
that's a theory
it's not really a theory we spoke about
this yesterday on the voicemail it's not
actually a theory in the scientific
sense it's the idle speculation
of someone who has no basis in fact for
making the claim
oh yeah Manhattan
pausing autism and how can we stop it
because once it's present I can tell you
as a doctor it's very difficult to treat
and as as a parent any of you with
autistic children know as a parent it
can take everything you have as a person
sometimes for the rest of your life as a
couple to deal with a severely autistic
uh affected child
all of you know that
autism now
is critically linked as these children
are coming forward in large numbers
to transgenderism whoa the two are
linked
imagine cheering for them
so do an inventory of what you have do
an inventory of your family any of your
friends gather together and understand
this mental contagion is infectious and
it's spreading and we've seen the
chapters now
coveted the illness
coveted vaccination a wave of autism
that's just burning us and now
transgenderism these all right so again
the argument he's making is vaccines
cause autism autism causes Trends now a
little background on Dr Peter McCullough
he regularly has spread uh baseless and
ultimately debunked medical
misinformation he's a cardiologist he
said we should be using
hydroxychloroquine for treating covid
that was determined he said that at a
time when there was no actual good
science saying that that was effective
we ultimately found found out
hydroxychloroquine is not effective for
covet he did the same thing with
Ivermectin at a time when we didn't have
a reason to believe Ivermectin was
affected ultimately a double-blind
randomized controlled trials determined
Ivermectin is not effective and on and
on and on now let's talk about a couple
different things here first of all the
wave of autism
there is a question and we're going to
actually do an interview on the show
about this coming up is there really
more and more autism or are we now
understanding how to better diagnose it
and there were lots of people who 20
years ago would never have been
diagnosed but they were autistic I've
spoken to friends of mine about
classmates we had in third fourth grade
and we now realize and they have since
been diagnosed as autistic in their 20s
and 30s they were always autistic
it just wasn't understood as well at the
time and so there's a question as to
whether there is a wave of autism or the
diagnostic criteria or better understood
regardless there's no evidence that
vaccines cause autism this all goes back
to 1998
Dr Andrew Wakefield put a study out in
the Lancet prestigious medical journal
the study has since been retracted and
Wakefield has lost his license it
claimed on the basis of 12 children that
there was a link between the MMR vaccine
and autism the study was retracted
Wakefield was found guilty of fraud
ethical violations Financial conflicts
of interest the data was bias selective
and falsified and he lost his medical
license
even if vaccines caused autism which
they don't there's no logical or
biological reason why autism would turn
people trans some autistic people may
identify as trans most don't some trans
people may be autistic most are not
there's no evidence that vaccines cause
autism and that autism influences gender
identity but this is a hero to the Maga
right this is the Maga Republican right
at an event held at Trump's Doral Resort
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
Christopher key Christopher key is a
political activist a former Fitness
professional and also the leader of a
group called The vaccine police
Christopher maybe you may recognize him
my audience May recognize Christopher
because he has been in the news over the
last year or two for both drinking and
injecting urine for reasons that he will
certainly tell us about Christopher I
appreciate your time welcome
uh brother my tie just fell off
well I think we'll be able to persevere
Christopher let me mention just so our
audience I fear no man I fear not Satan
let's do it brother go ahead um I will
let our audience know it I believe
you're either recording or streaming our
interview on your end because you are
you don't trust that we'll run the
interview as recorded is that correct
that's what you told me before we
started that is completely correct
brother I trust no no one in the
mainstream at all you guys are
prostitutes and and talking parents but
go ahead good so since we're both
recording it we'll have total clarity as
to what's said so let's start uh when
did you begin to drink urine and do you
drink only your own urine or do you
drink other people's as well
um I drink my own urine brother and
again I did I started this nearly 24
years ago
um I Heard
um a medical doctor talk about this and
I'm like that guy's a crazy nut and then
I heard David avocado woof avocado
David avocado wolf is a good friend of
mine and I heard him talk about it and
David's a little out there but I trust
the man and then I heard a third medical
doctor talk about it and I I I like
everybody I believes that you should
trust your lord and savior and test and
prove all things brother not some things
but all things and I'm like really Lord
I gotta really test and prove piss and I
began to do the research and I got the
book your own perfect Medicine by Martha
Christie and I read through that book
and I'm like oh my goodness brother this
could be real
um and again this is liquid gold and
which you don't understand David well
hold on Christopher I'm up I apologize
for interrupting already we have about
15 or 20 minutes and I you know I want
to learn by asking you questions but it
has to be a back and forth so I was just
asking how long you had been drinking
your own urine and whether it's yours or
other people's I think you answered that
so let me I I will mention to my
audience two of the folks that
Christopher mentioned David David
avocado wolf and Martha Christie are
both known medical disinformation
purveyors you can look them up
Christopher and I will disagree about
that and that's okay Christopher I just
am being clear with my audience is that
okay completely understood okay the
second question your question it was 24
years off and on for 24 years and yes
it's my own urine I don't drink anybody
else's urine okay what conditions do you
believe drinking your urine may cure or
prevent
again brother I'm not a medical doctor I
would never practice medicine without
license
um again I tell everybody don't believe
nothing I tell you but do what the Lord
commands each and every one of us to do
and then no but my question just what is
your believe me Christopher everybody
who watches this knows you're not a
medical doctor so don't worry about that
I'm just saying what do you believe the
urine does for you
okay well let me go in real quick to
help you understand this you understand
as a layperson that any poison that
comes in your temple your temple
instantaneously creates antibodies yes
or no my temple like the temple in my
head what do you mean you're I call the
temple your body because that's what God
calls it it's the body so do you
understand any poison that comes into
the body your body instantly creates
antibodies that is not my understanding
of the Medical Science but but neither
one of us are doctors right correct okay
good so I'm just what is it you're
treating or preventing with the urine I
don't try to prevent anything brother I
I drink it myself because I know it's
the perfect photonic memory of when the
cells were healthy okay because I know
through Medical Science any poison that
comes to this Temple instantly the
temple creates antibodies your liver
spins it and you piss it out and I
believe all you have to do is take it
back in and let me give you an analogy
real quick if you were to get bitten by
King Cobra you would take anti-venom
correct
I would I don't know I've it's never
happened I don't know what I would do in
a snake bite I'd call my doctor okay
call your doctor and your doctor would
give you anti-venom do you know how they
create anti-venom David
you know I don't I just don't know if
it's relevant to why you take your it's
very it's very revelant okay because the
way they create is very revelant the way
they create anti-venom is they take a
snake whichever snake it is the king
cobra for instance they milk it they get
that Venom they then inject it into a
horse or sheep okay they can inject any
animal or any person because
instantaneously that animal will create
the antibodies it's now in their blood
so they then re-inject the Horseshoe
sheep pull out the blood because the
blood now has the antibodies they spin
it and that is how anti-venoms created
David okay but Christopher is can can we
is there an answer to the question what
do you believe drinking urine does for
you
beautiful I believe anybody that's
taking the bio weapon are going to be
dead in two to five years and I believe
the antidote for those that have taken
the bio weapons what is the bio weapons
the bio weapon is what they call
covid-19 vaccine it's not it's not a
vaccine it's a bio weapon okay but
Christopher before we get to that before
we get to that and of course many people
received their first vaccine years ago
and they're fine so I don't know if
you'll eventually extend it to five to
seven years or seven to nine but
Christopher I want to wait a second
you've been you've been Drake drinking
the urine 24 years the covet vaccines
have only been around a couple years
prior to the covid vaccines what did the
urine do for you now you're saying it
protects you from the coveted vaccine
but before the covet vaccine what did
the urine do for you again as I told you
earlier and I don't remember if you
understood or heard that it's the
perfect photonic memory of when the
cells were healthy so I believe any
poison that comes in the temple the
temple creates antibodies the liver
spins it and you piss it out and I
believe one of the best things you can
do is take it back in not to mention it
is billions and billions of stem cells
do you understand you've already drink
your own urine David do you understand
that when you're in your mother's womb
you drink your own urine did you
understand that or no no that's not my
understanding of uh mammalian gestation
but Christopher let me ask you let me
ask you a different question is there
any medical science that supports any of
what you're saying here specific studies
you can point to
yeah I I sent your co-producer a long
list and anybody out there would get the
doc I mean the the book um your own
perfect Medicine by Martha Christie
there is a lot that book's been widely
debunked as disinformation let me ask
the question a different way is there
can I know you sent Pat a bunch of stuff
but now we're this is the show right the
audience doesn't see what you sent Pat
can you cite a randomized controlled
study proving the efficacy of drinking
urine
again I am dyslexic I'm LD I'm ADHD
um I'm D and Dumber and that's what's so
sad if I can figure this out David why
can't you take the time to do your own
research and your audience do your own
research and understand that the temple
that God created he created it perfectly
you know Christopher this is a show like
it's not it's not super interesting to
be like hey we're doing a show but you
refuse to cite any of the evidence and
tell the audience to Google stuff what
I'm asking is can you cite a single
peer-reviewed study that will tell us
what drinking urine will do versus a
placebo
again I sent all the data to your to
your friend your co-producer yeah I've
given you those clinical studies and um
I mean why can't you put them up on you
know for a quick link again I I don't
remember the actual side the reason I
can't put them up Christopher is we
didn't find in going through your list
anything that would meet the standard of
a randomized placebo-controlled urine
trial that proves the efficacy of
drinking urine for any condition
preventing or treating if we if you had
sent us something that met that standard
it would be all over the screen right
now but you're saying you don't remember
them but you've been doing this 24 years
again I told you I'm dyslexic I'm LD and
for me to remember a specific study
number no I sent you the book and again
your own perfect Medicine of Martha
Christie that you're saying it's
debunked or smart enough to go do the
research okay whether it's smart enough
to understand it or not so we'll leave
it at you is it would just so we can
move on is it fair to say you assert the
existence of such studies you're unable
to name them here but the audience can
Google it is that a fair place to just
pause on that so we can move on your own
perfect Medicine by Martha Christie yes
okay you've moved on it seems from only
drinking the urine to also injecting it
is that true
um I have and again I'm not a medical
doctor and I would never tell anybody to
inject Their Own no I know I have
injected my own urine correct what was
the reason hold on a second
what was the reason to switch from
drinking to injecting
again I drink and I also inject I do
both okay because many your listeners
understand stem cell therapy correct
some of them may but I'm just wondering
why you made the switch
again because I believe urine has
billions and billions of stem cells
especially if you age it okay and
instead of spending 25 to 50 000 going
to Mexico or going to different
countries to get stem cell therapy I've
got my own stem cells in my own urine so
I chose after doing the research to
inject it into my shoulders that I've
had reconstructed is the goal when you
inject to get it into the muscle into a
vein where where are you trying to
inject it
again you're trying to get me to
practice medicine without license and
now no no no no no I'm just asking what
you do I inject it into the muscle but I
would never tell anybody else to do that
Believe Me No One's Gonna Do it based on
you telling any saying anything on this
show okay so you inject it into the
muscle you talk about aging urine now
this is something that's interesting to
me do you ever I I apologize for the you
know seemingly strange language but do
you ever season or flavor the urine in
any way
um the the Aged urine can be very very
strong so I have added Stevia to it um
to make it a little bit more palatable
Stevie I I would have to kind of chalked
you up to be more of like a manuka honey
type guy
I I like that also but I've chosen to
use Stevia
um when you talk about the
um situation with the covid vaccine
which you've talked about and then just
to be clear just so we're meeting all of
the guidelines of all of the platforms
that we're on uh my views on the covet
vaccine are very clear I believe that it
is a safe vaccine I think the new ones
are not hold on a second Christopher we
each get time to talk I believe that the
the newest vaccines are not effective at
preventing transmission but are
effective at preventing death and
serious illness just to put that on the
record Christopher say that again I need
to hear say that one more time you
believe what well it's I believe all of
the data that I've looked at suggests
that against the newest variants the
bivalent vaccine is very good at
reducing the chance of death from covid
and not good at preventing infection
okay
okay as far as the covid vaccine goes
you and I don't know if you're familiar
with Sherry 10 Penny does that name ring
a bell to you it it does okay you and
Sherry and others have been saying
that tons of people are going to be dead
from the vaccine imminently a thousand
went out over a thousand let me just
finish the question Christopher get on
the playing field and you're not talking
about that hold on Christopher I have to
be able to ask a question I'm being
polite and giving you time let me just
ask my question
every time that you and Sherry say this
sort of thing the time frame is always
just beyond where we are with with
sometimes it's it's six months from now
and now it's been years and everybody's
fine and then it's two to five years Etc
why do you think the timing for the mass
vaccine death always is just a little
bit into the future
it's not brother have you not seen
what's going on with insurance companies
around the world I mean they're showing
you we're having death here in America
like we've never had before okay you
understand that if you take this
bioweapon the number one side effect is
clots microditis Strokes heart attacks
and death that's plain and simple and
you don't Christopher Christopher hold
on a second that's misinformation that's
misinformation the number one side
effect hold on a second hold on a second
let's be really clear the number one
side effect is arm soreness the number
two side effect is a flu-like malaise
the number three side effect is headache
and the number four side effect is fever
that's the truth Christopher are you
willing to admit that
again from the data that you're looking
at those are some side effects but also
blood clot Strokes heart attack death
and myocarditis are side effects would
you admit that yes or no I would admit
that there are some people who have had
myocarditis and pericarditis I don't
believe any have died from it and of
course the odds of that are a fraction
of the odds of muscle soreness is it
fair to say Christopher that when 90
seconds ago you said the most common
side effect is clot are you willing to
admit that's not true that the number
one side effect is muscle soreness
um okay muscle soreness would probably I
I would consider that that okay are you
willing to concede that fever is more
common than myocarditis
that fever is more common than
myocarditis um that is very possible are
you willing to concede that headache is
more common than pericarditis
again you're talking about three very
simple things that can happen with
anything so yeah but Christopher you you
you're the one who asserted that those
are the most common side effects and now
you're admitting that they're not so
that's the big admission from you isn't
it again I believe the the most
things that people need to understand
okay yeah sore arm fever those are all
very very possible but
blood clots Strokes heart attacks
microditis and death is very very likely
and again if dying of covet is less than
one percent of one percent of one
percent and why you would take this bio
weapon that we know we were the
experiment they they told you in the
past Christopher do you see how it's
tough to take you seriously right it's
tough to take you seriously when you
with full and total confidence say the
most common side effects of the bio
weapon are clot heart attacks stroke
death blah blah blah blah blah and then
within 90 seconds you're admitting hey
you know what what you just said isn't
true what David said is true would you
understand that it's hard to take you
seriously when you say inject urine no I
would not because again you know fever
and muscle armness muscle armness
again I misspoke so excuse me I
apologize okay I'm not as articulate as
you are that's okay okay but I'll try
um I believe again those are common side
effects for any and all shots that you
get okay so I'm telling about true
things that can cause death all right I
got you that this is your this is your
view as a non-doctor okay let me ask you
this you have um entered some locations
including Whole Foods including Walmarts
Etc what do you do when you is it that
you yell things at the pharmacy stuff
what I do let me answer what I do is I
go in and I give them the 11 undeniable
facts regarding all vaccines brother
regarding all vaccines and I put them on
notice okay and once they've been put on
notice if they continue to inject this
bioweapon into the people we can then
hold the them civilly and criminally
liable and it's very likely they will
all be hum because there is going to be
Nuremberg 2.0 brother the the one of the
things you need to understand and hear
me when I say that I've been part of
four national championships three so
super no but Christopher we can't just
steamroll this stuff you've made it
you've made a claim I want to understand
it who's going to be hung under what law
who gets hung here Nuremberg 2.0 is
coming David and those people that
blindly did not do the research and
understand what is happening they Contin
11 undeniable facts do you understand
David in 2010 the U.S Supreme Court
ruled that all vaccines are unavoidably
unsafe and white versus Bristols do you
not understand that I'm not familiar
with that case no but Christopher I
really let me tell you this okay I know
what I know because my greatest
accomplishment in life David is I'm a
father my twins were born with one of
the most rare diseases on the planet
called fennel kitchenoria otherwise
known as PKU where they'll never eat
protein no milk no chicken no cheese no
fish no birthday cake no ice cream
nothing that has protein would they ever
eat if they do it becomes toxic goes
straight to the brain it causes the most
extreme mental retardation David and
because of their rare disease I was
forced like everybody else should be
doing test and prove all things and when
I asked my pediatrician 24 years ago can
you show me the study that this new
schedule safe and he said sure
Christopher they're everywhere and I
said can I see it and he said right now
I said you're damn right right now
you're about to inject my children he
said nobody's ever asked me that but
I'll have it for you by your next
appointment my next appointment day but
I went in oh boy and he won't look at me
and he says Christopher there are no
studies but Christopher they have to be
safe you know Christopher um hey why are
you going to act like that as we talked
about
um before the interview you know we had
about 15 to 20 minutes today and we're
kind of coming to the end of that I
think you actually just maybe told us
the most important thing in this entire
thing and I actually am developing
radical empathy for you Christopher and
I'm going to tell you why you just
mentioned something very interesting you
said your kids have this rare condition
fennel ketonuria yes sir PKU that is a
condition
that affects many things but it affects
the urine significantly
I actually believe and I feel I feel
empathy for you for this I think it's
possible you've become obsessed with
urine
because of this condition that your
children have which makes the the urine
musty and mousy and I feel really bad
about that Christopher I think that
that's what's going on here is that
possible
no brother it is what's possible here
and problem is I did what my Lord
commands each and every one of you to do
and that is test and prove all things
and when I begin to look at the vaccines
that led me down looking at the food
that's all genetically modified that led
me to look at what they're spraying in
the sky that led me to look at the
poison your government David they don't
love you brother they're not here to
keep you safe and your listeners out
there you may think I'm crazy but
anybody out there that's listening to
David I challenge you these little paint
chips that you laugh about anybody out
there so many people are in pain right
now these little chips they work when we
did the randomized double Prime Placebo
studies at my University of Alabama
Christopher people don't even know what
you're talking Christopher just put a
sticker on his forehead which he says
cures pain Christopher listen let's have
you back to talk about the stickers
because we're just out of time I I do I
have feelings of radical empathy for
what is going on with you we've been
speaking with Christopher key he's a
political activist a former Fitness
professional the leader of the vaccine
police and Christopher as I told you we
don't cut these interviews up we're not
going to take you out of context it will
Air as recorded and I really do
appreciate your time today
brother I so appreciate you allowing me
to come on and tell my part of my truth
and anybody out there that's listening
my phone number is
205-936-9803 if you give me your name
address and email I will send these out
for free it'll prove to you that this is
real brother all right Christopher key I
appreciate your time sir
love you don't forget about my Dear
Antler vote brother the product that was
banned by the NFL the PGA major league
baseball and the NCAA because it works
so well brother all right thank you very
much
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
this is really a good one even Fox News
host Larry Kudlow is now saying to
Republicans it really doesn't seem like
you have evidence that Joe Biden
committed any crimes the example we're
going to look at is from yesterday this
is Larry Kudlow talking to Republican
Senator Ron Johnson remember that the
context here is that they supposedly
have a whistleblower or informant or an
informant on a whistleblower with
evidence of Biden crimes
they or he he or she is missing they
quite literally they say we don't know
where the person is and it's all just a
comedy of errors and now even on Fox
News Larry Kudlow is like you know you
don't really seem to have the evidence
and Ron Johnson goes with a classic
conspiracy line which is the lack of
evidence is the evidence because it
proves that the criminality has been
covered up this is a classic among
conspiracy theorists listen to this
folks this is just just embarrassing for
these people
Biden himself as vice president and
maybe as president has not yet been
clearly fingered uh the so-called he is
that's actually that's correct
they I mean they're trying they're
pointing but there has not been a
successful fingering of Joe Biden that
Kudlow is willing to admit it good for
him and maybe as president has not yet
been clearly fingered right uh the
so-called bribery allegations pay for
play by national affecting some kind of
uh policies hasn't that last step or two
Senator Johnson we haven't really
fingered him and I don't know how
important this informant is informant I
don't know if there's anybody else that
could do it but it seems to me that's
going to leave a very big Missing Link
yes called evidence well we need mean
all the bank records I know James Comer
hasn't been able to get all the bank
records but let's face it criminals hide
their criminal activity ah they don't
make it easy for people to uncover their
wrongdoing and so these investigations
are are painstaking you've got to you
know pick up one piece of evidence and
try and follow that thread to the next
piece and again when you've got a
complicit and corrupt media that won't
report the truth that shows in terms of
all the evidence we already do know of
the corruption of the Biden family right
we still elect this guy president and
they're still covering up for him it's a
real issue that's a sitting Senator
casually referring to the president of
the United States as a criminal absent
any evidence whatsoever and listen to
what he said the lack of evidence is the
evidence because criminals cover up
their crimes and it's the media's fault
this is classic conspiracy theory
circular reasoning where the conclusion
is assumed to be true and if there's
evidence that contradicts it it's
dismissed as part of the cover-up if
there's a lack of evidence that
contradicts it it's dismissed as part of
the cover-up example Q Anon right none
of the Q Anon predictions have come true
that would seem to suggest Q Anon isn't
credible
debunks The Conspiracy Theory right
wrong q and unbelievers believe that the
media is simply not reporting that Q's
predictions have come true
and therefore Q is right because the
media is lying by not reporting how Q's
predictions have come true oh well hard
to argue with that right because it's an
indefeasible statement so how do you
deal with this I don't know how do we
prevent people from falling into this
this trap there's not a simple answer
conspiracy theories
are extraordinarily complex and we've
had so many interviews about that
there's a psychological component social
cultural there's a political Dimension
and there isn't a one-size-fits-all kind
of solution
to disabusing people of conspiracy
theories particularly lack of evidence
is part of the evidence so
it's like a broken record we need to
educate people in critical thinking how
to evaluate a source of information
understand whether a statement being
made is a statement a fact or a
statement of opinion what is evidence
and what is speculation what is accepted
science and what is pseudoscience all of
that we need to engage with the
conspiracy theorists respectfully and
empathetically which I understand is
really tough to do because many of their
ideas are certainly worthy of being
mocked and then third we we need to
create an environment we're abandoning
these conspiracy theories is welcomed
rather than I told you you were an idiot
we need to make the environment where
you abandon the conspiracy theory a
welcoming one where it's like it's so
great that you came to this conclusion I
think this is great and you know
honestly having done this you'll
probably be less likely to fall for
stuff like this in the future that sort
of thing
but it it is not an easy task and when
even on Fox news they are getting to you
seem to kind of be lacking evidence here
you know that there is absolutely
nothing there and that is abundantly
clear at this point in time Marjorie
Taylor green is weighing in on the
missing whistleblower or informant who
is fingering Joe Biden with crimes as
Larry Kudlow said she doesn't care that
there's no evidence she doesn't care
that The Whistleblower is missing
Marjorie Taylor green believes that the
Whistleblower will end the presidency
of President Joe Biden listen to this
they're whistleblowers yes they are
missing they're either in court uh
they're in jail or we cannot talk with
them at this time because they can't be
found this is a very real situation that
we're it's very real except there's no
evidence and the people making the
claims are missing but it's totally real
talking about and our investigation is
so important Steve
um that this will bring down the
president of the United States and I
want to let everyone know something
we're going back to the treasury
Department today at one o'clock okay
because we have more financial records
that we have to review uh leading to the
Biden family and Joe Biden himself is it
possible that the whistleblowers were
evaporated by the Jewish space laser run
by Soros and Klaus Schwab or whoever is
in control of the thing you know they
should really put Mike pillow in charge
of the whole whistleblower thing if Mike
pillow were in charge it would just be 2
more weeks until we get all of the
whistleblowers evidence and testimony
naturally of course it would be
perpetually two weeks until we got it
but at least it would be only two weeks
you know these people it it is funny
okay when you see Marjorie Taylor
Green's face and she she's pretending to
see her or maybe she is seriously saying
this whistleblower is going to be the
end of the presidency this is going to
be it for Joe Biden he's not going to be
able to survive this there is a funny
component I admit there's a funny
component but these are people who for
Generations have said we are the party
of Law and Order and yet forget about
evidence of crimes without even probable
cause without Reasonable articulable
Suspicion without a single document that
we might count as evidence without even
The Whistleblower The Whistleblower is
missing she can say with a straight face
this is going to be the end of Joe
Biden's presidency and if it were up to
them they would have already removed
Biden despite the fact that Biden has
done nothing to make himself worthy of
removal from the office of the
presidency that's really the scary thing
and tens of millions of Americans at
minimum have fallen for it and they may
re-elect they may re-elect Marjorie
Taylor Green in 2024 they may put Trump
back in the White House in 2024 and so
the takeaway here is We cannot put our
guard down the Eggman called the
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P and said you know we cater to
delusions all the time Republicans keep
talking about catering to delusions when
it comes to trans but what about the
fact that all these Republicans are
constantly catering to delusions from
Christianity when it comes to making law
in the United States the Eggman says it
much more eloquently than I do
said that catering to the delusions of
the trans people is just bad politics
because it's such a small population
if they were delusions she's absolutely
correct Dave however catering to the
delusions of the Christian slash
Catholic God Believers is good politics
ask Trump
Shalom right right yeah no there is a
double standard and we know that there
is a double standard when it comes to
well
you know uh uh Corinthians and John and
Paul they say the following about
poverty or abortion or gay marriage and
we should be taken seriously when in a
civil government proceeding we invoke
our scripture
to influence what the law should be take
us seriously well but a lot of people
don't believe that you could you could
say that that is a religious delusion of
yours that you're imposing on everybody
else and saying listen to me go by what
I believe based on the supposed sacred
nature of the text that I'm probably
misunderstanding anyway but then when it
comes to trans then they have a very
different perspective the Eggman is
absolutely correct I have very little to
add we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today we will talk about Paul gozar
facing questions over a staffer's
alleged far-right links we will talk
about the new IRS free e-filing system
that the tax prep Giants are Furious
about and vice media once worth more
than five billion dollars has filed for
bankruptcy the latest in the media
downfall that is afflicting many
BuzzFeed news and others all of it on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com you'll get instant access
otherwise I'll see you back here
tomorrow
thank you
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
they're Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman davidpackman.com NYC